Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr.
[inaudible]. If we have an animation.
Movie or a computer game with quadruples,
and we are yearning for really high quality life-like animations motion capture
is often the go-to tool for the job.
Motion capture means that we put an actor in our case, a dog in the studio,
and we ask it to perform sitting trotting pacing,
and jumping record its motion and transfer it onto our virtual character.
There are two key challenges with this approach. One,
we have to try to weave together all of these motions because we cannot record
all the possible transitions between sitting and pacing,
jumping and trotting and so on.
We need some filler animations to make these transitions work.
This was addressed by this neural network based technique here.
The other one is trying to reduce these unnatural foot sliding motions.
Both of these have been addressed by learning based algorithms in the previous
works that you see here later bipeds were also taught to
maneuver through complex geometry and sit in not one kind of chair,
but any chair, regardless of geometry,
this already sounds like science fiction.
So are we done or can these amazing techniques be further improved?
Well, we are talking about research. So the answer is of course, yes.
Here you'll see a technique that reacts to its environment in a believable
manner. It can accidentally step on the ball stagger a little bit,
and then flounder on the slippery surface
and it doesn't fall and it can do much, much more.
The goal is that we will be able to do all this without explicitly programming
all of these behaviors by hand. But unfortunately, there is a problem.
If we're at an agent that behaves according to physics,
it will be difficult to control properly.
And this is where this new technique shines.
It gives us physically appealing motion and we can grab a controller and play
with the character like in a video game.
The first step we need to perform is called imitation learning.
This means looking at real reference movement data and trying to reproduce it.
This is going to be motion that looks great is very natural.
However,
we are nowhere near done because we still don't have any control over this
agent. Can we improve this somehow? Well,
let's try something and see if it works.
This paper proposes that in step number two,
we try an architecture by the name generative adversarial network.
Here,
we have a neural network that generates motion and the discriminator that looks
at these motions and tries to tell what is real and what is fake.
However, to accomplish this,
we need lots of real and fake data that we then use to train the
discriminator,
to be able to tell which one is which so how do we do that?
Well,
let's try to label the movement that came from the user controller inputs as
fake and the reference movement data from before as real,
remember that this makes sense as we concluded that the reference motion looked
natural. If we do this over time,
we will have a discriminator network that is able to look at a piece of
animation data and tell whether it is real or fake.
So after doing all this work, how does this perform?
Does this work well sort of, but it does not react well.
If we try to control the simulation, if we let it run undisturbed,
it works beautifully. And now when we try to stop it with the controller,
well, this needs some more work, doesn't it?
So how do we adapt this architecture to the animation problem that we have here?
And here comes one of the key ideas of the paper in step number three,
we can rewire this whole thing to originate from the controller
and introduce a deep reinforcement learning based fine tuning stage.
And this was the amazing technique that DeepMind used to defeat Atari breakout.
So what good does all this for us? Well,
hold onto your papers because it enables true user control while synthesizing
motion that is very robust against TAF previously unseen scenarios.
And if you have been watching this series for awhile, you know, what is coming,
of course, throwing blocks at it and see how well it can take the punishment.
As you see the AI is taking it like a champ.
We can also add pathfinding to the agent. And of course,
being computer graphics,
researchers throw some blocks into the mix for good measure.
It performs beautifully. This is so realistic.
We can also add sensors to the agent to allow them to navigate in this virtual
world in a realistic manner. Just a note on how remarkable this is.
So this quadruple behaves, according to physics,
lets us control it with the controller,
which is already somewhat of a contradiction.
And it is robust against these perturbations at the same time.
This is absolute witchcraft and no doubt it has earned to be accepted to
SIGGRAPH,
which is perhaps the most prestigious research venue in computer graphics.
Congratulations.
What do you see here is an instrumentation for a previous paper that we covered
in this series, which was made by weights and biases.
I think organizing these experiments really showcases the usability of their
system weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning project. Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you're an academic or have an open source project,
you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through wnb.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to weights and biases for the longstanding support and for helping us
make better videos for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.